I was thinking about because you've had
so many career arcs you just have had
multiple sections in your career where
you including right now which is
stunning to me you have three movies
coming out in four months which you've
never done before at 85 years old yeah
that never happened to me before okay
yeah well it didn't happen to you I
think you had to agree to it at some
point I mean you this is you no I I did
I agreed to it I didn't even really
understand at the time see I've we
finished me and Lily Tomlin finished the
seven years of Grace and Frankie a week
later we started a film together called
moving on and then that was short
I needed a fix I needed Lily I I've
missed her so it was a physical thing
yeah and then 80 for Brady came along
and it was with Lily and yes but also to
get Rita Moreno and Sally Field I mean
it's just in addition to Lily Tomlin
it's it's an incredible yeah all of you
are out there kicking ass yeah having
well we had such a good time I've Loved
Sally for as long as I've Loved Lily
I've known both of them since the 70s
and I I always wanted to work with Sally
and to watch her build her character and
this movie was such a thrill you know
it's interesting because it I've heard
you talk about
you have these friendships with women
now that was not the case when you were
young no you had a different attitude
towards women it's an old frame of mind
that I hope is disappearing that says
when you grow up what that means is
you're no longer emotional you're no
longer needy
you stand on your own like a guy
that's the signal of adult maturity
and that plus the fact that my mother
had done away with herself I thought you
know I think you were 12 when that
happened and even before then I thought
no women are losers the best thing to do
is to hit your wagon to him an alpha
male yeah and then everybody's going to
want to be around him and so you'll you
know come in on his coattails and I felt
that way until I was about 60.
really yeah it took me a long time over
that well that shocks me because I would
have thought I could see in the 60s that
being a mentality that you have but then
no the stuff that happens in the early
years it's why you have to do your best
parenting then stays with you a long
time and so I just I had no women
friends only men friends and then I had
a daughter in my 30s and and I left my
France life with my husband and
everything and I moved back here and
became an activist and the people that
really impacted me were women and they
were women like I had never met before
the way they behaved the way they
treated people it was like looking
through a keyhole at the world that we
were all fighting for and I just thought
wow I want some of that yeah so I
started bonding with women like that all
younger than me smarter than me braver
than me and they they helped me so much
you know it's amazing that
you could have that anyone could ever
have the idea that men are the strong
ones because anything you learn later on
as you go through life is that women
you know women are the backbone and I've
been to so many countries where they
openly say I mean in Haiti they'll tell
you oh it's the women it's the women
it's true that that the women leave they
get educated and then they come back and
they are trying to hold this country
together yeah all over the world you're
right it's women who are leading the
fight against the climate crisis all
over the world there are many many
profound reasons why this is true maybe
it'll have to be for another talk Conan
which would be interesting to have this
is the birds and the bees talk no
I am 59 years old and I'm still waiting
on that talk because I don't know how
any of it works
um but no it's it's interesting women
um
women have so many psychological and
emotional advantages that give them
great strength and I think it goes all
the way back to the hunter-gatherer
times in fact yeah women in their DNA
understand interdependence women know
that we are all connected and we're
connected to the Earth and to other
species
women aren't afraid of expressing need
you know women friendships
right yes oh God I need a hug in fact 80
for Brady one of the things that I like
the most is there's a scene with Lily
when I can I can I need a hug you know
man you never hear men saying to a guy
friend I need a hug or tell me what to
do I'm really lost yeah and women laugh
together differently women's friendships
are face to face eyeballed eyeballs
men's side by side looking out at things
women cars sports events and things like
that they don't ask
for help I think it's a one reason why
women live on average five years longer
than men do used to be seven years we've
lost a little ground there
um but it's all is your child a boy or a
girl I have two boys two boys twins yeah
oh man yeah yeah that's why when you're
talking about masculinity I I'm making a
very conscious effort to try to make
sure that they don't grow up with those
types of Hang-Ups yeah if you want I can
come over anytime and hug your husband
in front of your children okay that's
really a weird thing they're trying to
help them
I want to model this kind of masculine
don't model anything
okay I won't help them remain
emotionally illiterate yes they're born
emotionally literate let them keep that
don't let coaches and fathers and
teachers shut the shut that down